destrucción y un total de fallecidos aún
sin confirmar este es el panorama que
deja el ciclón bats irá a su paso por
madagascar mientras el fenómeno
meteorológico se aleja se empiezan a
contabilizar los daños la ciudad de
manjar y por donde la tormenta tocó
tierra quedó destruida
aquí casi el 95% de la ciudad ha sido
destruida por no decir al 100% como
podemos ver ahora la carretera está
cortada el mar ha subido imploramos al
estado que venga a ayudarnos lo antes
posible la oficina de gestión de
desastres del país informó que no tenían
el número exacto de fallecidos al tiempo
que daba a conocer que unas 47 mil
personas fueron desplazadas a pesar de
que el ciclón vacila y se aleja
persisten las lluvias y las inundaciones
misionaria mansión ya hayek ton fusta
gracias a dios aquí no se han reportado
fallecidos pero como representante
oficial de este barrio puedo decir que
el daño es grave el viento era muy
fuerte y aunque la gente tuvo cuidado de
proteger sus pertenencias ha habido
muchos daños
hora de la mañana el agua subió y todo
el barrio quedó bajo el agua antes del
paso de basura y madagascar se
recuperaba de los daños causados por el
ciclón tropical ana que dejó al menos
unas 55 personas muertas a causa de los
derrumbes inundaciones y
desprendimientos de tierra que provocó
en su recorrido